fox's lucas tomlinson is live in that
country right now where it's a little
after 2 20 in the morning lucas can you
hear me
i sure can tucker just moments ago u.s
officials told me there are several
russian warships underway from crimea
carrying russian marines heading in the
direction of odessa ukraine's third
largest city and they're preparing for
an amphibious assault thursday tucker
now earlier explosions rocked ukraine's
capital city
[Music]
russia has fired over 450 missiles into
ukraine it's not always clear if they
are hitting their intended targets this
is kharkiv's national university and
regional police department on fire in
ukraine's second largest city roughly
the size of dallas the ukrainian
government says two thousand civilians
have been killed since the start of the
war last week this air base near kharkiv
another dramatic video of what the
russians have unleashed on this country
the situation on the ground looking more
like grozny and syria not the improved
and modernized russian military that
moscow is boasting about pre-invasion
and british intelligence say five
ukrainian cities are now surrounded the
russian defense ministry for the first
time put out casualty figures today
tucker said 498 russian soldiers have
been killed and 1500 wounded tucker
lucas thomason thanks so much for your
straight reporting i appreciate it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else